-Our next guest tonight
is a Tony- and Emmy-nominated
and Grammy Award-winning actress
who you know
from her work on Broadway
in "The Color Purple"
and "The Piano Lesson."
She reprises the role of Sofia
in the new movie version
of "The Color Purple,"
which is in theaters
on Christmas Day.
Let's take a look.
-A pretty girl like you
can take his mind,
but you can't have his money.
-He ain't got no money.
See, my sister
and her husband say
I can live with them
as long as I please.
Now, I come here
out of respect.
But if there ain't none to get,
there sure ain't none to give.
Don't keep me waitin'.
-Please welcome back
to the show,
our friend Danielle Brooks,
everybody!
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Now, you -- you, my friend,
are in celebrating clothes.
-Oh, my gosh.
I think, every time I come here,
I get sexier and sexier.
-You do!
-Ooh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
So do you!
-Oh, my God, thank you
for saying that.
-The hair is popping.
-Thank you very much.
-Yes, we're celebrating.
-You were nominated
for a Golden Globe.
-Yes.
-Nominated just today.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Just today for
a Critics Choice Award.
Congratulations.
-But, you know,
I got a beef with you.
-What's that?
-First of all, that's a lot
to celebrate -- good stuff.
But I've been on this show
four times now.
-Yeah.
-And I think it's time
we pop a bottle.
You know what I'm saying?
We got a lot to celebrate.
You don't ever have nothing.
Oh! [ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Here's to you
and all your successes.
-Thank you!
Okay!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. Yeah.
That was worth it.
-Was it worth it?
I'm glad you thought
it was worth it.
-I do, I do.
-This is -- "The Color purple"
is a very exciting film for you.
The first time you were here,
2016, was
because you were
in the Broadway show.
-Yes.
-And we talked about
how cool that was, because
that had been the first --
that was the first Broadway
show you ever saw.
-Yes, first Broadway show
I ever saw.
10 years later,
first Broadway show I star in.
-Wow.
-And now, almost a decade later,
first studio film.
-That's amazing.
-[ Squeals ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank y'all.
It's been an amazing ride.
-I mean,
how has your relationship
with the character changed over?
I mean,
do you feel closer to it,
do you feel like
you have a different perspective
on it, having done it?
-Oh, definitely different
perspective, deeper perspective.
It's really cool because
it's not often that an actor
gets to step into the theater
and do it in film
with the same character,
so it's been a thrill.
Like, it's been
so, so, so, so cool.
And getting to bond
with people like Miss Oprah...
-Yes.
-...and Taraji and Fantasia
and Colman and Corey.
It's been a dream.
-And now this is the role
Oprah played in the film
in the '80s.
-Uh-huh.
-And she's a producer
on this film.
How -- Has she
given you advice or...
-She has given me advice --
a lot of advice.
But, you know,
the number-one thing is,
when I got to talk to her
about this character --
finally got the courage to talk
to her about the character --
I actually asked her, in our
hour-and-a-half conversation.
I said, "Can you pray for me?"
And she did, and I'm so glad
she did, because
you know she got a direct
connection and line to God.
So if you're going to get
anybody to pray for you...
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-...it better be Oprah Winfrey.
-Oh, my God, that's great.
-My life has changed completely
[Laughs]
ever since that conversation.
-Yeah. Um, you mentioned
Corey -- Corey Hawkins.
And so he is your costar
in this film,
and he -- you were classmates
together at Juilliard.
-Yeah.
-So is that first year
at Juilliard, you meet Corey?
-Oh, my God, yes.
-Wow. So you're kids.
-In 2007, we met.
Isn't that crazy?
We were babies.
-That's amazing.
-We've been cutting up
ever since.
But he's seen every valley,
hill, mountain.
We've climbed them together.
And so finally we here
in "Color Purple" together.
-And you mentioned cutting up
together for a long time.
And so here you are, you're
in a studio film together.
And it just must be so surreal,
because, obviously, you know,
this is a work of humor,
but it's also a very heavy film,
and it just must be so nice
to be with a friend
you've been friends with
for a long time.
And you have a video
you want to share.
Corey maybe ate too much
during...
-Crafty? He spends
too much time at crafty.
-That's at craft services,
where all the food is.
-Yes. Right.
And so after eating too much,
his pants kept popping on set.
And I just thought it was
the most funniest thing,
so I had to -- I begged him
to take this video for me.
-Now, the most fun part
about this video
is how hard
you're laughing off camera.
[ Laughter ]
And it's nice to know this is
not the first time
it's happened,
and you're still laughing
like it's the first time.
Let's take a look at Corey.
-[ Laughs ]
Wait. Okay.
[ Both laughing ]
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God! I love it.
Like, people who don't
take themselves too seriously.
-I know.
-You know what I mean?
And now he's, like,
running a marathon.
So he's all skinny and slim now.
-Okay, gotcha.
Oh, that's very nice of you
to point that out, as well.
-I had to look out for him.
-He stopped.
He's going the other direction.
-Yeah, other direction.
Can I -- Your daughter, Freeya,
is four years old.
-Yes.
-Here she is.
She looks absolutely gorgeous.
-Little Freeya.
-And she's so beautiful.
You tried to get her
in the film?
-Seth, I tried everything.
-Yeah.
-Because this is
historical moment.
-Yeah!
-I was like,
"I'm gonna get my baby
in this film.
It says there's a toddler.
They need a toddler.
My baby's gonna be
the toddler."
-Yeah.
-We got her dressed,
we got her in hair and makeup.
-They were okay with it.
The director knew.
Everybody signed off.
-Everybody.
We even got her --
like, you know,
you got to sign union papers.
-Yeah, exactly.
-She was excited.
Miss Thing decided,
"It's nap time,
and I'm not here for it."
-Really?
-Yes, and she was supposed to go
into Fantasia's arms
at the end of the movie.
And she said, when Fantasia
tried to get her,
"Don't touch me!
Please don't touch me!"
And I was like, "Oh, my God."
And as soon as that happened,
Blitz was like,
"Danielle, I'm sorry your baby
ain't gonna cut it.
She got to go."
[ Laughter ]
So, yeah, unfortunately,
my child is not in the movie.
But we have a great story.
-Yeah, you have a great story.
It's good to know that
there's always a backup child.
-Always.
-Yeah.
-That might be a little older
than the toddler.
-Exactly.
-[ Laughs ]
-But we have a really
wonderful video for you.
So you took her to see
"Little Mermaid."
-Oh, my gosh,
I took her to see Halle Bailey
in "The Little Mermaid,"
and I saw that the trailer
was coming on,
so I had to get it on tape.
And I got a video of my daughter
watching her mommy
in the trailer.
-It's really a wonderful age
because when you watch this,
she really can't wrap her head
around what's happening.
-No, she doesn't know.
She's four.
Now she's four.
She was three at the time.
So, yeah, her first movie
that she's ever seen.
And she got to see Mommy
in the trailer.
-And the best thing about it
is she feels like
she's breaking news to you.
-Oh, my God.
And to everybody
in the theater.
-Yeah. Look at this
incredible video of Freeya.
-Oh, Miss Millie.
Ain't got no kinfolk
around these parts.
-That's you.
-[ Laughs ]
-That's you. That's you.
♪♪
Mommy!
-[ Laughs ]
-Mommy.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, are you trying
to make me cry?
-It's so good.
-You're trying to make me cry.
-I -- It makes me cry.
Also, does she always dress
like that for the cinema?
-Yes.
-She does?
-As of today, she will be.
-Yeah, but is that --
Like, I just --
I was watching it
the second time.
I'm like, "Ah, she really
is wearing a tiara."
-I know, because -- Well,
they have all these outfits
at the store
for "Little Mermaid,"
and it came with a tiara,
so I put her in tiara, yeah.
She's in theme.
-She looked great,
and it was very sweet to watch.
Congratulations again.
One more toast to you
and your nominations.
-Thank you. Thank you, friend.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Danielle Brooks, everyone.
"The Color Purple"
will be in theaters
December 25th.
Stick around.
We'll be right back
with music
from Alexander Stewart.